hi guys scifi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead today i'm
going to explain a 2012 action fantasy
movie called wrath of the titans this
movie is a sequel to the 2010 movie
clash of the titans but you can fully
understand the movie without having to
watch the previous one
the movie takes place several years
after perseus the half god son of zeus
defeated kraken after the event perseus
decides to live as a normal human being
and refuses his dad's offer to rule at
his side even after his wife's dead he
now lives as a fisherman with his 10
year old son helius
they seem to enjoy their mundane life in
the small village
one night zeus suddenly visits perseus
and asks for his help saying that the
powers of the gods are fading since the
humans have stopped praying to them
however there is a huge consequence they
must face
the gods will become powerless and
mortal and the wall of tottarus the
underworld prison of the strongest
titans and monsters will fall and the
imprisoned demons will break free and
attack the earth
perseus refuses to get involved in the
army and chooses to live with his son he
then politely asks for his father to
leave
the next morning zeus goes to tartarus
where he meets his brothers poseidon and
hades and his other son aerys he offers
hades his help to rebuild the wall of
tartarus and suggests he forget the past
but it seems like hades still cannot
forgive his brother for kicking him down
to the underworld he summons the minions
and they start attacking zeus and
poseidon poseidon is severely wounded in
the ensuing fight and ares has also
picked sides on hades he hits his father
ruthlessly and takes away his weapon the
thunderbolt
zeus is then tied up and hades reveals
that kronos will allow them to keep
their immortality if they free him he is
delivered to chronos the strongest titan
and the father of the gods ares
ruthlessly punches his father to express
his jealousy towards his brother perseus
while kronos starts draining zeus's
energy depicted with fire all around his
arms
meanwhile the twin-headed monsters
called the chimera emerge from the
underworld and begin attacking the
nearby villages one of them is perseus's
village realizing that he must protect
his son at all costs perseus brings out
his old sword and armor and fights the
chimera after the long chase since the
chimera keeps running away and attacking
innocent people he manages to chain the
monster and lure to kill itself with its
fire blast he then brings his son to the
mount of idols which is completely run
down due to the lack of people coming to
worship the gods
he prays to zeus but the dying poseidon
arrives instead he tells perseus that
hades and ares have joined kronos and
zeus has been captured he orders him to
travel to the underworld himself and
free his father before that he suggests
perseus to find agnor the half-god son
of poseidon to assist him he then turns
into ashes and hands over his trident to
perseus the demigod then prepares
himself and flies on pegasus to the
campsite of queen andromeda's army where
egnor is being held upon arrival the
army gives him a warm welcome since he
is considered a hero after killing
kraken the queen personally greets him
but suddenly the commander comes in
telling the queen that they have lost
more than 300 men only to kill four
chimeras and urging them to pray to ares
however perseus interrupts telling them
not to pray to him since he has become
humanity's enemy it is revealed that
andromeda's men have imprisoned egnore
for stealing crown jewels perseus
informs him that his father poseidon has
passed away and urges egnore to help him
get to the fallen one he agrees and the
queen releases him
agnor andromeda perseus and several
soldiers embark on a journey to the
hidden island where the fallen one or
hephaestus is hiding
perseus explains that he is the one who
created the gods weapons zeus's
thunderbolt hades pitchfork and
poseidon's trident
he adds that these weapons can be
combined into the spear of triam the
only weapon that can defeat kronos they
then unchain agnor and he uses his
father's trident to direct the boat to
the island
upon arrival the reckless agnor steps
into a trap they can't cut the
counterweight since the fall will
immediately kill him suddenly a wild
cyclops a huge monster with one eye
appears and starts chasing perseus
the soldiers attempt to assist him but
another cyclops shows up and attacks
them terrified a female soldier secretly
prays to ares
perseus tries to fight back and manages
to stab the monster's hand with his
sword the monster resists but he is able
to reach the rope that causes a big
trunk to fly in and hit the cyclops when
perseus shows them the trident they
immediately release agnor and lead them
to hephaestus he warmly welcomes them
however he does not recognize agnor even
after he tries several times to convince
him hephaestus concludes that agnor is a
useless demigod that's why he doesn't
know him hefbestus has lost hope after
he knows the truth about the gods but
the charming queen begs him to help them
since she reminds him of his wife he
agrees to help the blacksmith reveals
that he is the designer of tartarus
informing them that there is a shortcut
to the center of the prison
on the other side zeus's condition is
getting weaker and crono starts to
awaken again
hephaestus guides them to the entrance
of tatarus while showing them a map to
navigate the path into the labyrinth
upon arrival suddenly ares confronts
them thanks to the soldier who prayed to
him earlier he easily eliminates all the
soldiers while the blacksmith attempts
to open the entrance door he even kills
the prayer
since the door only stays open for a
short period of time he uses his staff
to hold the door and deliberately
sacrifices himself to distract ares
while perseus agnor and andromeda
reached the door without hephaestus
agnor tries to read the map to direct
them and they eventually arrive at the
core of the labyrinth
they explore it and the path comes to a
dead end suddenly the labyrinth begins
to move rapidly and continually shifts
at some point andromeda is trapped and
almost gets killed but luckily the men
managed to free her however perseus gets
cut off from the group falling into a
room where a wild minotaur appears and
attacks him the fight ensues the
minotaur is strong enough and manages to
slam perseus to the wall several times
he eventually gets his chance to
counter-attack and kills the monster the
labyrinth begins to move and he reunites
with agnor and andromeda again
they finally arrive at the heart of
tatars where kronos has absorbed all the
power from zeus
zeus apologizes to his brother as he
forgives hades for his actions ares
confronts the gods hades eventually
regrets his action and fights ares while
the group arrives and tries to unchain
zeus with the trident
meanwhile kronos has fully awakened and
begins to move
after several attempts perseus releases
his dad while ares intervenes he throws
hades's pitchfork towards zeus which
successfully impales him
using his remaining power zeus manages
to bring all of them excluding ares out
of tatarus they arrive at a base where
andromeda's army is gathering and
immediately carry the dying zeus to the
tent
zeus reminds perseus that only the spear
of triam can defeat kronos
since he has retrieved hades's pitchfork
and poseidon's trident he needs to lure
aries out to take zeus's thunderbolt
from him he prays to ares challenging
him to a one versus one duel at the
temple of the gods
meanwhile queen andromeda explains the
strategy for facing kronos to her army
their main mission is to hold kronos
back for as long as possible
not long after the volcano explodes and
several four-handed monsters emerge from
it attacking the soldiers the war
between monsters and humans ensues
at the temple perseus finds out that
ares has kidnapped helius he
deliberately brought helius to watch his
father die
they fight but it seems like he is much
stronger than his brother
he easily subdues perseus ruthlessly
slamming his head to the pillars
helius tries to challenge ares by
pointing his sword at him
using this opportunity perseus manages
to attack him and stab him in the chest
with a knife he activates zeus's
thunderbolt and destroys him with it
perseus then combines all the god's
weapons into the spear of triam
the monsters are very strong and easily
eliminate the humans army but they don't
give up and they keep giving a tough
fight using his remaining power hades
forgives his brother and transfers his
power to zeus they come out from the
tent and help the human army to fight
the monsters finally kronos emerges from
the volcano and with their power
combined hades and zeus try to strike
the titan
equipped with the spear perseus
immediately flies towards kronos
meanwhile the titan throws a fire blast
and starts running towards the army
kronos attacks again and this time zeus
has to use his remaining power to
protect hades from the blast
on the other side perseus eventually
reaches out to kronos attacks him with
the spear and finally throws the spear
of triam into the titan's stomach
completely destroying him before dealing
more harm to earth after that perseus
approaches his father who says his final
words and gratitudes to his son before
disappearing into ashes
meanwhile hades has spent all his power
and goes away
perseus then meets andromeda and kisses
her at the end of the movie he hands
over his sword to helius and decides to
train him to be a soldier
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching